in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Martin
and Anita are with us hey how are you
hey welcome you guys good to have you
thanks for having us and where do you
guys live New Jersey right outside of
New York
very cool good good excellent welcome to
Nashville I'm here to do your debt-free
scream yes sir and how much have you
paid off one hundred and seven thousand
excellent and how long did that take 21
months all right very cool and your
range of income during that time 242
about just a little over 300 Wow
excellent you guys are killing it what
do you guys do for a living I work in
finance and I'm in law enforcement
all right good very good so what kind of
debt was this 107,000 everything from
car loans to student loans 401 k's 401k
loans rather credit card you name it we
had it we were normal you were normal
every possible kind of debt Under the
Sun yep Wow very so tell me the story
what happened 21 months ago made you get
so intense and knock it out so fast well
we were sick and tired of being sick and
tired as you say all time and just went
home one night after I come home from
work I spoke to my wife I'm like what
can we do to get out of this debt and
she actually googled that debt snowball
no we're getting out of debt what kind
of like that so um I open up our Amex
your favorite I know and I just looked
at the bill and it was just crazy and
there wasn't anything big on it you know
like it was just $30 zero or $50 there
and he's never been into credit cards
but being in finance you know credits
great for an economy and that whole you
know yeah so we just we just got tired
of being tired it just felt like when we
first got together we're like well when
we make X that's it we're gonna we're
gonna be killing it and then we made
that and we surpassed it and we just
felt more and more broke so we just kind
of took us that step back and we said
let's do something crazy and uh
literally he was right I google just
budget not even
getting out of that by just budgeted
budget the envelopes came up and then
you came up and I think it took us point
one seconds to get on board start
listening to your radio show podcasts
Wow read the book and what half a day
yeah I mean we had it I sucked in some
when the student is ready the teacher
will appear because if this was six
months before I would have been like no
I'm in finance I have a finance degree I
work in New York City you know I had all
that stuff but that's not how that's not
reality with three kids yeah well you
make enough money live in New York City
it's just a matter of not being broke
yeah yes Wow excellent excellent
very cool so what do you tell people
when they ask how you paid off a hundred
and seven thousand dollars and 21 months
what's the secret to getting out of debt
each other honestly when it comes down
to it um the way we look at this we feel
we feel very blessed that you know we
came to know of you um but the money
part is really the dollars or the the
tangible aspect of this whole habit
changing you know every year I would get
my bonus that could very easily just
paid that off but it went to something
else you know we weren't in a city
looking for our Rolex eyes meanwhile we
still had two car payments and all this
other stuff so it's um the the money
aspect is really just a tangible and the
secret is understanding that you're in
this together and there were times that
I would come home and you know I'd say
well it's not fair because I want this
and I deserve this and this and that and
he would say but why this is what we
have the grand scheme one thing it
allowed us to plan and to really it was
really each other you have you have to
get on the same page the whole
accountability partner there's there's
nothing greater than that and we were
very lucky I don't know
what's a secret everything you're saying
other than yes dear what's the secret
sir no but really we just we look at you
know our friends and we look at just our
society in general you know we had kids
pretty early especially for the
Northeast so we have three kids and
everyone always asks you know how do I
work when I have three kids and it
really comes back to because I have a
partner in my team is working together
and this money thing
just kind of fit right into it and the
way we sort of work is if there's
something that he feels strongly about
then I get on board with stores that can
happen it doesn't work out and if
there's something that I feel strongly
on board about then he gets on board and
we kind of make it work that way at the
end of the day it's really just the two
of us very cool very well done excellent
job what was the hardest part of this
for you all once you decided to do this
you had a good-sized shovel and a decent
sized hole you were in so what was the
big thing that the moment where you had
to overcome something not trying to keep
up or not or saying or realizing because
you know we're we're on a cusp of
Millennials and not to give Millennials
a bad name but sometimes you know our
generation feels entitled and we deserve
this and we deserve that and just really
being like you know it's okay not to
have X Y & Z I mean in the last seven
years that we've been married or just
about seven years we've had probably
more brand new cars that most people had
in a lifetime why because every two
years we needed a new car you know and
just really sitting down and being like
you know what you don't need that car it
doesn't make you happy going on a walk
going on a drive when we started doing
the envelopes we were crazy intense and
we had like no money and are going out
envelopes so on Sundays we well we got a
minivan with a third baby and on Sundays
we would get in the car and we were a
drive literally like an hour away each
way put the DVD on and we would talk we
talk about our future which we have so
many plans and we can do it now very
cool very cool
excellent well done all right it's mark
and Anita and the three babies names are
Ava Zachary and Julie all right in their
ages five three and ten months today all
right very cool very cool all right mark
and Anita and the gang from the New York
City area a hundred and seven thousand
dollars paid off in 21 months making 240
to 300 count it down let's hear a debt
free scream three two one we're dead
well done well done well done oh that's
fabulous I love it well congratulations
you guys that's a lot of debt paid off
very very quickly very proud of you hey
guys thanks for watching if you enjoyed
this video click the subscribe button to
get the latest content and check out
these other great clips from the show so
you have to break the cycle you have to
flip this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind